welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and with Marvel's what if season 2
many Marvel fans can't help but ask what
if ourselves in many ways Marvel feels
like its best days are still ahead of it
but in others it kind of feels like
somewhere down the line we skewed onto a
Darkest Timeline a reality that we
weren't necessarily meant to be in if
you look back at the history of all of
Hollywood there are countless Nexus
points in history in which the timeline
veered onto its current course but away
from a completely different and equally
exciting existence specifically there
was a singular moment 10 years ago in
the development of the first Ant-Man
film in which Edgar Wright director of
Sha of the Dead Hot Fuzz and Scott
Pilgrim versus the world left his dream
project of directing Ant-Man setting
Marvel Studios on a destined path of
committee prev visualized fever dreams
called things like quantam Mania but
instead of its current Kang headaches
could we have had a more badass Avengers
in the Fantastic for sooner so inspired
by the what if series we at new rock
stars decided to Embark upon a new
series where we will explore the endless
possibilities and thrilling timelines
that were erased in an instant as we ask
the question what it time space reality
movie franchise building is more than a
linear path it's a prism of endless
profit possibilities where a single no
thanks on a head shot can Branch out
into Infinite better plot lines pitched
on YouTube by nerds nerds who would make
terrible movies have ever given the
chance follow one of these nerds and
Ponder the question what
if it's Friday May 23rd 2014 The
Hollywood Reporter publishes a joint
statement from Marvel Studios and
director edar Wright saying the studio
and director have parted ways on Ant-Man
due to differences in their versions of
the film the decision to move on is
amicable the statements and shock waves
throughout the nerd world shaking to the
core those who were delighted by Edgar
Wright's test footage for the film shown
at San Diego Comic-Con in July 2012
according to the book MCU the reign of
Marvel Studios by Joanna Robinson Dave
Gonzalez and Gavin Edwards chapter 21
right man wrong time the trigger point
happens the week prior mid-may 2014 when
a nevern named in-house screenwriter
under contract with Marvel Studios turns
into a rewrite of Edgar Wright and Joe
cornish's screenplay to apply notes from
the Studio's shadowy creative committee
this revision left Edgar Wright quote
horrified meanwhile this exact same
month of May 2014 Marvel Studios
president Kevin feige was bsy courting
Sony Pictures head Amy Pascal to
convince her to share the character of
Spider-Man in a 2016 reboot in Captain
America Civil War after The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 underperforms the first
weekend of May 2014 Kevin feige calls a
top secret Summit with his closest
advisers in a Santa Monica Hotel leading
to a faithful meeting with Pascal on the
Sony lot Pascal threw her sandwich at
Kevin feige and told him quote get the
out of here but she comes around to the
deal and both Studios make billions but
did Kevin feige's focus on locking down
the Spider-Man deal in those days of May
2014 blind him from what was happening
on Ant-Man right under his nose did this
distraction allow the then rival
creative force of the company of the
creative committee to hijack Edgar
Wright's Ant-Man script and change it so
much that Edgar Wright had to walk away
what were these rewrites who was that
faithful in-house writer and what would
an MCU steered by storytellers like
Edgar Wright have looked like let's
rewind it's 2000 Marvel sells the film
writes to Ant-Man and several other
characters including Captain America man
thing and The Punisher to Artisan
entertainment Edgar Wright at that point
known only for the UK sitcom of space
pitches Artisan on an Ant-Man Heist
movie based on his memories of John
Burns Marvel Premiere number 47 from
1979 including Scott Lane's origin story
but Artisan passes 2003 Lion's gate buys
artisan and they allow the rights to
Ant-Man to revert to Marvel 2004 Edgar
Wright now the director of Shaun of the
Dead meets Kevin fige and Avia Rod at
Comic Con they say they never knew about
his Ant-Man pitch but his treatment now
impresses them but it's still just 2004
these men aren't yet in a position to
greenl an Ant-Man movie it's now 2006
Edgar Wright is promoting Hot Fuzz and
at ComicCon Kevin feige now eager to
prove Marvel as its own studio in its
own Cinematic Universe convinces right
to join him on stage he Nam drops
Ant-Man and he says listen to the
characters I Nam that we that we work
are working on currently and you put
them all together there's no coincidence
that that may someday equal The Avengers
2008 Wright and Cornish turn in their
Ant-Man completed script to Marvel by
now the smash release of Iron Man
transformed Marvel Studios into a
juggernaut with a growing Cinematic
Universe Marvel commissions a second
draft of Ant-Man but the project takes a
back burner so that Marvel can roll out
its phase one plan and Edgar Wright can
focus on Scott Pilgrim versus the world
2011 ant-man's second draft is turned in
according to the MCU book it was quote a
sleeker version of the same story a
heist movie that featured both Pim and
Lang trying to keep the Ant-Man suit
away from a villain who wants to use the
technology for nefarious purposes Marvel
hoped to include Ant-Man in The Avengers
lineup for 2015's Avengers Age of Ultron
June 2012 Marvel pays Edgar right to
film a day of test footage which
includes a scene of Ant-Man played by
stunt actor fighting two men in a
hallway resizing running down the barrel
of a gun a concept reused for the final
version of the film this footage is
shown at ComiCon in July 2012 but Edgar
Wright instead decides to complete his
Cornetto Trilogy with the world's end
with longtime producing partner Eric
felner who had been diagnosed with
cancer Marvel agrees it's now October
2013 ant-man's release date is set for
July 2015 production is scheduled to
begin in May 2014 in development begins
December 2013 Paul Rudd is announced to
play Scott Lang winning the role from
the runnerup Joseph Gordon levit this is
followed by announcements of Michael
Douglas as Hank Pim evangelene lily as
hope vany Michael paa as Luis and
Patrick Wilson as Darren cross Edgar
Wright hires cinematographer Bill Pope
the legend behind the lens of the Matrix
Sam Ry Spider-Man 2 and three Scott
Pilgrim and later on for Marvel Studios
shuni and as fate would have it the
cinematographer for Antman the wasan
Mania January 2014 the friction begins
according to the MCU book wrri and
Cornish deal with an endless stream of
new notes from this creative committee
so what is this committee this is a
Brain Trust assembled by Marvel CEO Ike
perom mutter in the design of Pixar's
Brain Trust created by Steve Jobs but
the Marvel committee included Marvel
entertainment president and Ike
promoter's mouthpiece Alan fine Marvel
Comics Legends Brian Michael Bendis Joe
Casada and Dan Buckley and from the
studio side Kevin fige and Lou despasito
this Brain Trust was really though based
out of New York and reportedly through
Ike permut and Alan fine averse to any
film that they believe they couldn't
sell toys with as they came into the
Marvel game through a successful toy
company called toy Biz and in pear Ms
View they could not profit from sales of
any toys that would include women and
non-white heroes not the best guy in
this Watcher's view according to the MCU
book the committee's notes for Ant-Man
included questions about Hank Pimp's
past with shield and a relationship to
Tony Stark's father Howard wri and
Cornish Revis their script trying to
preserve their original tone however
until March 2014 when Wright and the
committee agreed to postpone the
beginning of production to the month of
July to sort out script issues at this
point Marvel Studios hands-off write
script to an in-house writer who does a
new pass to address all of the creative
committee's notes all of the notes so
who was this writer in the early years
Marvel Studios was experimenting with an
in-house writers program that included
emerging screenwriters like Christopher
yoast who wrote on Thor the Dark World
and Thor Ragnarok Edward reort writer of
the Now You See Me films and episodes of
Jessica Jones Nicole Pearlman writer of
the first drafts of Guardians of the
Galaxy and Captain Marvel Joe Robert Co
co-writer of both the Black Panther
films Drew Pierce writer of an early
version of runaways and co-writer of
Iron Man 3 was Shane black and Eric
Pearson who wrote on the scripts of Thor
Ragnarok and black widow this writer's
program was initially overseen by Marvel
producer Steven brousard who was Kevin
B's former assistant but then taken over
by Nate Moore actually after the success
of the 2012 Avengers film Jos weeden's
new contract with Marvel allowed him to
do writing passes on All Phase 2 Marvel
movies to set up Age of Ultron for the
most success in interc continuity but
according to Jos Sweden Edgar wri's
draft of Ant-Man was perfect no notes
Jos Sweden says quote I thought that was
not only the best script that Marvel had
ever had but the most Marvel script I'd
read I had no interest in Ant-Man I read
the script I was like of course this is
so good so the mystery in-house writer
was not J Weeden it was likely just one
of those writers just trying to do their
job to carry out orders from the
committee while Kevin feige was across
town trying to dodge Amy Pascal
sandwiches but edar Wright is horrified
by this new draft according to the MCU
book the story is mostly the same but
sads of dialogue have changed and
references to the wider MCU you were
shoehorned in
shoehorned oh one shot energy huh I
think I'll try
it
[Applause]
w so what does one shot's Focus shoe
do see
[Music]
eternity
wa so uh one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with ones shot
energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com new rockstars for 10% off
your
[Music]
order which leads us to our May 23rd
2014 Nexus point Edgar Wright leaves
publicly and his department heads all
drop like flies cinematographer Bill
Pope production designer Marcus Roland
Patrick Wilson has to leave due to
scheduling conflicts Kevin feige later
said I wish it wasn't as late in the day
as it was but it had just become clear
that there was an impass that we had
never reached before we've worked with
lots of unbelievable talented filmmakers
like Edgar before and of course there
are disagreements along the way we had
always found a way around it a way to
battle through it and emerge on the
other side with a better product it just
became clear that both of us was just
being too polite over the past 8 years I
guess then it was clear that oh you're
really not going to do that note all
right this isn't working Edgar Wright
would later say I wanted to make a
Marvel movie but I don't think they
really wanted to make an Edgar Wright
movie having written all my other movies
that's a tough thing to move forward
suddenly becoming a director for higher
on it you're sort of less emotionally
invested and you start to wonder why
you're there really it's now summer 2014
Edgar W script is revised by Paul Rudd
and Adam McKay who said that they
fleshed out the character of Hope vany
after evangelene Lily had almost walked
from the film due to W's departure so
this new draft included a new flashback
prologue with Howard Stark and Peggy
Carter and Hank Pim and a sequence with
Falcon and Avengers compound Payton Reed
is announced its director Cory stole
replaces Patrick Wilson as Darren cross
August 2014 Kevin feige finally wins his
Cold War against the creative committee
after the surprise success of Guardians
of the Galaxy a movie that they fought
Disney Chief Bob Iger finally told I per
mutter in the committee to back off a
fuggy and let Marvel Studios move
forward with a bigger budgeted civil war
with Robert dowy Jr to move forward with
a black panther film and move forward
with the captain Marvel film Kevin feige
now had full creative control over the
studio and he laid out his new grand
plan in October 2014 at Kevin Khan at
the elcy toown theater July 2015 the
Ant-Man film releases making $180
million in North America and $519
million globally not avengers level
money but enough money so that Ant-Man
could return in Civil War in Ant-Man in
the WASP an Avengers endgame and Ant-Man
in the WASP Quantum Mania the 2023
launch to Marvel's Phase 5 and
Multiverse Saga that introduced Kang the
Conqueror to be this franchise's next AR
Arc villain Payton Reed himself helps
cast Jonathan major in the role and he
would first appear in Loki season 1 most
recently November 2023 Edgar Wright
finally opens up on Instagram saying
having signed an NDA when I left there's
not much I can say I guess the biggest
pun intended differences in off screen
play was that it was self-contained and
didn't have cameos from other MCU
characters apart from an nt's and it was
much more of a crime Heist movie with
interlocking robberies in heists
throughout a little like Donald
westlake's The Hot Rock I think the
crucial difference too was that like the
original Comics Scott Lang was an actual
criminal at the start of the film and
not already a 100% good guy we felt it
was a more satisfying Redemption AR if
he went from Criminal to Hero so we take
you back to our Nexus moment in May 2014
what if Amy Pascal never threw her
sandwich at Kevin feige what if she
shook his hand for that Spider-Man Civil
War deal right there on the Sony lot
Kevin feige's coup of Marvel Studios
would have come 3 months earlier and he
would not have have had those Troubles
of summer 2014 so imagine it a
triumphant Kevin feige drives from Sony
and Culver City to Marvel's offices on
Disney Burbank Studio Lot he drops by
Nate Moore's office to tell him now that
I got Spider-Man there's no way the
committee will stop us from doing black
panther by the way how are those latest
notes on Ant-Man moris says well one of
our writers applied all the notes the
committee wanted take a look and fing
reaches out a hand UNS smeared by Amy
Pascal's spicy brown mustard grabs the
script flips through it and tells Nate
Moore you know what tell the committee
to shove it we're shooting Edgar wri's
Ant-Man as is the script is locked so
from here dear viewer we skew into a
branch timeline it's summer 2014 Edgar
Wright moves forward with his version of
Ant-Man Cory stole modok erased Patrick
Wilson as Darren cross Yellow Jacket
there's no Howard Stark Peggy Carter
prologue there's no falcon fight at The
Avengers compound Bill Pope shoots
incredible action scenes including the
ones we saw in the final film that wri
originally conceived The Gun Barrel run
the toy train fight it's now July 2015
Edgar R Ant-Man opens with Scott Lang
not on his way out of prison as a good
guy who just tried to stop his evil
employer vistacorp but a straightup
criminal remember Edgar Wright cited The
Hot Rock which begins with Robert
Redford leaving prison and taking a job
to steal what a gem from a Brooklyn
Museum that is of great significance to
a country in Africa from which it was
stolen during colonial times wait a
minute you might ask does this not sound
like the introduction to killmonger in
the London Museum in Black Panther a
script written by Marvel in-house writer
Joe Robert Cole in this alternate
timeline Kevin feige and Nate Moore who
are now eager to FastTrack Black Panther
and set up his appearance in Civil War
turn out to bully Edgar Wright even more
aggressively to merge his Ant-Man
concept with the broader MCU anyway
that's right the committee notes weren't
coming from New York they were coming
from inside the house but as men who
know how to work a Hollywood set they do
it with more finesse and they make a
better case than the committee did with
more respect for Edgar Wright's Vision
so instead of a shoehorned falcon Cameo
feige and more softly encourage Edgar
Wright to include a black panther Cameo
and a plot to recover stolen vibranium
from wakanda stolen by Patrick Wilson
Darren cross using vibranium dealer
ulyses Claw from Age of Ultron which
would give yellow jacket in this version
of Ant-Man a suit of vibranium now our
Edgar right would bristle at these MCU
tie-ins but they do fit in more
organically with his plan to follow the
hot rock in this way he's allowed to
maintain Scott Lang as an anti-hero
which is always more important to him
anyway he sticks with this Scott plus
Hank heist with Michael Douglas in a
Romancing the Stone throwback but in
wakanda and the movie Works rather than
making 500 million globally Ant-Man as a
team up with tchala in a Prelude to
Black Panther becomes an even bigger hit
making 800 million worldwide leading us
to alternate 2016 rather than Marvel
Phase 2 and three movies shot with the
desaturated tones and poor lighting and
steady can of the Russo Brothers the MCU
now becomes known for a vibrant clean
Scot Pilgrim visual language brought by
Edgar Wright and Bill Pope 2017 since
Wright and cornish's draft left the role
of Pope vany smaller in this universe
any Ant-Man sequel now would not further
explore the wasp and the Ant family but
rather ant-man's role as the mcu's
sharpest de Edgar Wright now sees the
benefit of playing in Kevin feige's
sandbox of characters and ant-man's
appearance is a team up with Spider-Man
and Spider-Man homecoming Scott Lang as
a criminal helps fellow empathetic
criminal vulture Adrien tombs break into
Avengers Tower leading to the spider
versus the ant bug Bowl 2018 2019
Ant-Man now plays an even bigger role in
the infinity war in endgame films rather
than waiting for a rat to release him
from the quantum realm so he can Babble
about time dilation and turn into a baby
we learn that Scott snatched the time
Stone just before Thanos destroyed the
Infinity Stones or found an atom-sized
piece of the time Stone and the Avengers
use this to rewind time and the time
travel logic of Avengers endgame makes a
hell of a lot more sense 2021 rather
than exploring the depths of the quantum
realm Edgar Wright who is still kicking
around his ideas for heist movie like
baby driver or a 60s Nostalgia piece
like last night in SoHo now pitches
Marvel on an Ant-Man prequel Allah
Godfather Part Two following Old Man
Hank Pim but back in the 1960s which
Marvel Now could use to introduce a
lineup of the Fantastic Four in the
1960s so in this revised timeline Marvel
no longer uses an Ant-Man sequel to
introduce Kang the Conqueror a villain
who has very little to do with Ant-Man
historically in the comics but instead
establishes the Ant-Man Legacy as a
lineage with a history with the
Fantastic 4 and with Victor Von Doom a
character who does have a history with
Ant-Man after himself being shrunken
down to Micro World which is why in the
comics the Fantastic 4 reach out to
Ant-Man Hank Kim for help to begin with
so now now it is 2023 in the Edgar
Wright timeline and Ant-Man has teamed
up at this point with black panther with
Spider-Man with the Avengers he has
darted down the grooves of thanos's
Gauntlet and he brought to the MCU the
Fantastic 4 and Victor Von Doom so
naturally Edgar Wright is hired to
direct Marvel's Fantastic 4 it's his
moment in the Sun and to fill out this
cast Edgar Wright relies on the actors
that he ended up casting for baby driver
in our timeline John Ham as Reed
Richards ASA Gonzalez say Stu storm on
Elgort as Johnny Storm Jamie Fox as Ben
grim and who better than Kevin spy as Dr
Victor Von D wait oh no no no no no no
oh God no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
no it seems like no matter what the
Multiverse Saga is destined to be a bit
complicated Edgar Wright is of course a
more interesting director when he's not
trying to build a Cinematic Universe
just as we've learned that directors
like Tao a Titi are destined to be bored
with this kind of World building the
reality is we would have gotten one good
Edgar Wright Ant-Man film and then
Marvel Studios would have watered down
the character so that he'd better fit
with their Visions for Civil War and the
infinity Saga and we would be having the
same what if thought experiments
meanwhile the trajectory of Amy Pascal's
pastrami on Ry had much further
consequences than Fig's blindness to
Ant-Man which merits further discussion
on a future episode but the more Marvel
Studio struggles to align its Vision
with bold directors we will always look
back at Edgar wri's Ant-Man and wonder
what
[Music]
if